the amazon rainforest used to be called
the earth's lungs for the way it
absorbed carbon and emitted oxygen but
over the past dozen years that process
has begun to slow and in some places
it's even started to reverse
ranchers have cut down millions of trees
to raise cattle there for the beef and
leather that's consumed across the globe
the world's biggest beef producer jbs of
brazil has vowed for years not to take
cattle from illegally cleared land but
over many months bloomberg analyzed more
than one million delivery logs and found
a jbs supply chain that's deeply
embedded in deforestation hot spots
jbs says it follows brazilian law to a t
and has no way of knowing if any of the
cattle it's buying originated on
deforested land
but what bloomberg discovered during a
trip into the heart of cattle country
was that jbs doesn't go beyond what's
required of it to try to find out
like money cattle can be laundered
illegally deforested ranches
breed calves and then sell them to
middlemen who then sell them on to the
direct suppliers that supply the
slaughterhouses it's a well-known
maneuver in the amazon region and one
that people don't even bother trying to
hide because it's grounded in a legal
system so full of loopholes that
prosecutors environmentalists and even
the ranchers themselves consider it a
farce
[Music]
jbs says it has a new approach to
finally map its full supply chain from
the ranches where cattle are born to the
slaughterhouses where they die but it's
been promising that for more than a
decade and unless there's a significant
change to brazilian law and enforcement
it's unlikely to have the effect that
the world really needs which is to
eliminate deforestation from the supply
chain of a company that slaughters a
third of all cattle coming out of the
amazon biome
as one researcher told me jbs is focused
on zero illegality not zero
deforestation and there's a big
difference
bloomberg's story was produced in
partnership with the pulitzer center's
rainforest investigations network
[Music]